so i was doing some research recently on
the topic of autophagy
and i want to share with some
interesting data um one of the biggest
benefits
of doing a fast is autophagy
and so there's other benefits to
anti-inflammatory
weight loss fat burning anti-aging and
the list goes on and on
and it is true when you look at the
actual definition of fasting
it's basically the absence of food
you're not eating anything
you'll be drinking water but nothing
else so let me just first explain
autophagy
autophagy is a garbage disposal it is
breaking down stuff that shouldn't be
there
things that are toxic and turning all
that into brand new
building blocks to make new tissue so
it's very anti-aging
and it also helps a lot of different
conditions especially inflammatory
conditions
neurodegenerative conditions heart
problems
alzheimer's parkinson's anything
inflammatory so autophagy
is a very therapeutic thing and one of
the biggest triggers
is when you do fasting for a period of
time
if you're consuming plants that are rich
in phytochemicals
that will enhance your autophagy it will
not inhibit
your autophagy so we have the
phytochemical curcumin
from turmeric which is a spice and then
we have
resveratrol which yes it's in red wine
but the wine will definitely
block autophagy because of the alcohol
or you can get it from another
supplement called knockweed extract
which is very very powerful
then you have sulforaphane which is a
very powerful phytonutrient
which is in cruciferous vegetables it's
a type of a larger category
called glucosinolates there's
probably more research on this
phytonutrient than any other
phytonutrients out there
when you're consuming raw cruciferous
vegetables you are
triggering autophagy if we take the
autophagy benefits
from both fasting and phytonutrients
in cruciferous vegetables and add the
additional anti-cancer benefits
it's going to help you remove more
damaged proteins from the body
one type of protein that is toxic on
your body is the accumulation of
misfolded protein
or glycated protein which is a
combination of
sugar and protein together realize i'm
not talking about your muscle protein or
your ligament protein
i'm talking about the tiny biological
machines that are doing all the work in
the body
most of them are enzymes they're made
out of protein
and when they get misfolded or glycated
they accumulate and they clog things up
in your brain
they're involved in a lot of
neurodegenerative diseases they're
definitely involved in cancer
autophagy gets rid of this stuff it
increases stress
resistance so your body actually can
tolerate more stress
especially if you're going through
chemotherapy for example and you choose
to do
chemo let's say with a fast
and cruciferous the autophagy effect
will increase the resistance to
chemotherapy
even the chemo and the radiation will
have a less negative effect on your
cells
autophagy also helps you stabilize genes
and by getting rid of the damaged cells
you're left with
functional cells which will also
decrease your risk for cancer
overall it will extend your life i
recommend that you experiment with this
you can do like for example broccoli
sprouts
or cauliflower or kale during a fast
and just evaluate your results you can
get it as a food
or as a food concentrate in a supplement
and lastly i just want to mention when
you see the research on fasting
you'll usually also see fasting
or calorie restrictive diets right well
cruciferous vegetables have extremely
low calories
and their nutrient dense especially with
the phytonutrients
i challenge you to experiment with this
and type your results down below
hey we're back with another amazing
recipe no grains
no sugar totally keto there's no
suffering in keto
absolutely not karen and it's an immune
system builder
absolutely you have to check this out i
think you should hurry up
watch the recipe and make it yourself
it's just so easy to be
keto but is it simple it's super simple
we hope you enjoy making it as much as
we are enjoying eating it